[ __ ] the way show faces
so i have a quick question
um i have been engaged for
two years
and
i that was cute work yeah 50 60 hours a
week
he works 50 60 hours oh geez
and
you know people ask us like when's the
date oh
when are you gonna get married
and you know we don't get the bags baby
you know yeah
my question is do you think it's okay to
be engaged for a long time
and
you know how to respond when people ask
like when's the [ __ ] wedding you know
because none of the bags and you know i
want to get married he doesn't care as
much about as much as me about like
having a big one you got a [ __ ] you
don't say you know [ __ ] because balls
are underneath i want to but naturally
you know it's just not in the cards
because you've got balls on the other
side of his anus you know that's my
question so thanks guys love the pod
thanks uh [ __ ] all those people that ask
when's the date dude when somebody says
they're engaged i don't even think oh
when's the wedding what the [ __ ] are
these people no well i mean this is a
perfect [ __ ] spin move mentality dude
hey when's the date when i wanna and
twist yeah well yeah moonwalk but i've
never agreed with that but i agree with
it this time yeah but also that how much
is that [ __ ] girl for real the girl
that they would cast in a movie where
that's how she's supposed to be [ __ ]
looking ugly and then she gets done up
and people are like wow when she's even
hot like that yeah i mean she's already
so funny that's what you're saying yeah
she's not yeah that's what i'm saying
but like she would be like
like that's how they would dress her
yeah and that [ __ ] like rachel cook i
was just gonna she's like she's so hot
with his glasses on like that's how
that's what it would be yeah um so uh
yeah dude um
it's okay to be engaged for a long time
[ __ ] be engaged for ten [ __ ] years
yeah dude only be engaged die in game
die engage i agree i have kids have a
whole family never get have good kids
get married first grow up get married
and be like mom and dad why you're not
engaged be like because you [ __ ]
people like you [ __ ] keep on
asking spin away have your kid pass on
the spin move mentality that's what's up
made it about the spin move mentality
but yeah die engaged that's a good
that's a good guy engaged and you get
tattoos that say that die engaged oh
that's cool so so german die
yeah yeah yeah don't sweat the question
dude [ __ ] those [ __ ] well those people i
mean that's just a natural question to
ask i would i don't ask it come on don't
be
i don't ask it dude i don't i don't
[ __ ] even think it to be like yo dude
come on with that question just be like
that yeah that's good come on what the
[ __ ] are you gonna be one of those guys
yeah before they even finish the
questions
or go like this go like this yeah we're
engaged and then before they say
anything go like me when's the day
that's good that's great that's the best
one yeah yeah right yeah
that's the best one actually yeah
scratch everything that we said before
hello
[Music]